foreign
never buy anything from an Instagram ad
thank you I'm actually not telling you
I'm telling me this yeah thank you for
reminding me I need to have this video
just for myself and so if someone else
listening to this or watching this gets
value from it great this is not advice
for you this is simply a directive to
myself never buy anything from an
Instagram ad because I am always
disappointed even I as one of the
titular minimalists I
have been bamboozled by an Instagram ad
and it happened to me again recently I
know it happened a few years ago but I
have several t-shirts now including this
one which are either really faded or uh
they have holes in them to the point
where it's like I need to replace a few
of my t-shirts what are you talking
about that that's cool no it's uncool
again oh it's okay yeah it was cool from
2017 to 2022. it doesn't make you look
distressed it just makes you look
stressed
yes and so it looks makes you look uh
manic a little bit and so what I noticed
recently as I I saw and I somehow
Instagram knew I had a hole in my shirt
and they're like hey you need a new
shirt did you have a hole in your shirt
yes
hey Josh
uh and so I I'm going through Instagram
I'm getting ready to post a real for our
podcast on Instagram about the hole in
your shirt no no I'm sorry I'm sorry
thanks to Danny he made this reel to
post and I posted up on there and as
soon as I do an ad pops up it's like hey
these are the best fitting t-shirts and
here's what other guy's shirts look like
and here's what these shirts look like
and so I'm like you know I do need three
new shirts so I'm gonna go ahead and buy
three new shirts from this company and I
buy them from this company by the way it
doesn't matter which company it is and
that's the point I try to drive home
because the shirt that fits me well may
not fit you well at all but I get the
shirts and they just are mediocre the
quality is mediocre the fit is mediocre
they're fine right but they're just as
fine as father bought a few I usually
buy my shirts from eBay why didn't I
just go do that again because I
essentially get them for sale anyway and
quite often they're either new or like
new or close to New they're in really
great condition and I'm not paying the
retail store tax so to speak because
your clothes lose 90 percent of their
value as soon as you walk out of the
store as soon as you open the box in
your home as soon as you try it on or
wear it for a day all of a sudden it's
lost most of its value so I go to eBay
I'll buy shirts whenever I need them but
even I fell victim to the tug of
advertisements yeah it seemed convenient
and Instagram makes it so easy now and
here's what happens here's why we do the
sucky ad segment on the podcast which is
coming up next and we're going to
torment TK with this one I mean we're
talking about a sucky ad this week where
finally TK is not going to be able to
play The Devil's Advocate or Angel's
Advocate or any advocate for this ad at
all I finally found the bulletproof
impenetrable ad that just sucks there's
only one that's never been made and here
it is you know you know what's funny
about the Instagram ads is I get caught
on the um they must know my ADD because
like it's all these the fidgety things
like just this really cool keychain like
these two magnets are on it but you can
do all these cool things with these two
magnets I'm like I would love to waste
my time doing that oh my gosh what a
metaphor I would and that's that's the
thing I would love to waste my time with
this but because I do understand that
tug of advertisements I'm like no you do
not want to waste your time like that
anyway now we have a Counterpoint from
Professor Sean he said one of the things
he he purchased something from Instagram
at and he's glad he did yeah I I feel a
little ashamed though that I purchased
it because of an Instagram ad I saw the
ad over and over and over and over and
it eventually wore me down so it still
wasn't the most deliberate purchase but
this tablet that I use right here to
keep our show notes on it's a remarkable
2E ink tablet use the coding
et cetera Etc
oh that's even better
um but I'm very happy with the purchase
I've been using it for like three years
it's one of the most useful tools I own
uh that doesn't mean that I feel good
about buying it because because of an
app because of an ad yeah it's funny you
say that because had I bought those
shirts and they worked out really really
well for me I would still feel like oh I
wish I would have found these a
different way because I don't like
supporting the advertisement industrial
complex let me explain what I mean by
that real quick because that's why Sean
jokes by the way use this fake promo
code because we don't do any ads on the
podcast and the reason we don't is we
don't want to part participate in that
system I think there's a better way
unfortunately we've set up the internet
that we are most things that are created
we're forced to watch advertisements on
them in order to consume them for quote
free right and that's why I love the
conversation about Bitcoin that we were
having a bit earlier because the
technology behind Bitcoin I think will
dismantle the in the advertising
industrial complex because it will
enable quick efficient seamless almost
frictionless micro payments to people
whom you appreciate their work because
right now the the barrier of Entry is so
high if you want to support our private
podcast you have to have a patreon
account or sign up for a patreon account
you have to input your credit card
information all of these things that are
non-native to your everyday life yeah
that's absolutely absolutely right like
the the way our our monetary system
works is is such that you need a third
party to mediate disputes you also need
a third party to secure the form of
currency you need a third party to help
prevent double spending and other kinds
of problems like that and what that
means is we have to pay money in order
to pay money which is why whenever you
go to buy something and you see like a
minimal credit card fee right like if
you're buying something that's under
five dollars you got to pay in cash well
it's because in order to process a
credit card payment they've got to pay a
fee to Visa Mastercard American Express
or whatever in order to make that
possible all transactions that we make
economically involve some third party a
banker a credit card company that's
making it possible for us to give one
another money apart from like cash I
can't give you a dime without going
through another system I've got to get
your bank account number and we've got
to go through Bank of America or chase
or something like that and the
possibility of Bitcoin is that we would
be able to exchange resources in a
peer-to-peer manner without relying on
that third party and that means we don't
have to pay money to pay money in quite
the same way we do now and what that
means is now we can actually do trans
transactions at a fraction of a fraction
of a fraction of a fraction of a penny
we don't know what the world looks like
when I'm able to pay you something that
is a tenth of a tenth of a cent now you
might say well who's going to charge a
tenth of a tenth of a cent well when you
don't even have the possibility when you
don't even have the option of charging
that much for a service your creativity
doesn't flow in that direction but now
what happens to online tipping tipping
online content consumption what happens
to financing projects you now have an
alternative that comes into place with
the possibility of micro payments that
can challenge the advertising industry
that can challenge the traditional
subscription model for paying for things
because we simply don't have that
available
and the underlying technology of Bitcoin
allows us to secure a monetary system in
a way that doesn't require this
third-party involvement as we know it
and so that is like really exciting to
think about and although most people are
told and sold about Bitcoin on the basis
of like hey put your money on this
speculate and you might get rich it's
like no like that's that's the stuff
that's exciting for someone who wants to
sell you something but what's really
exciting is man this could completely
revolutionize the way we do exchange I
think if we want to get rid of
advertisements and we see fewer
advertisements on our Instagram feed or
whatever then this is one Avenue that we
may want to take because it gives us
back the power the power of being the
consumer not not the consumerist but the
consumer we all consume some things and
if I can reward people for the things
that I want it connects me directly to
the people from whom I'm getting value
and then I give them value back with
less friction oh that's a beautiful
world did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free